I could have music yab I'm trying to
hook up to my sound system I you will
have music it was very stressed
yesterday because the only thing he knew
how to do was to plug his iphone to his
stereo but he wanted to have his iPhone
but when I said why don't you plug your
iPad to your stereo he went oh my god
yeah there's a way to do it I just like
your iPod in maybe you need a dongle
but plug your iPad in if you have the
dollar you got to get the dongle
dumb girls make me angry they're the
worst [ __ ] you I always starts shorting
out after a while no you know wouldn't
have had dongles Steve Jobs yeah of
course Steve Jobs wouldn't have any of
this garbage it's Harvey wouldn't had a
pencil that you Charlie sticking in the
side of a [ __ ] mechanism you know
what Steve Jobs said you got five
styluses on your hand yeah why would
your phone come with a stylus yes oh hey
that Tim Cook comes he's like what about
the Apple pencil yo we got it I got one
we're gonna have a we're gonna have a
pad that charges all three devices your
watch your headphones on you and your
phone oh wait a minute
we can't do that yeah I just dreamed it
last night what do you mean they can't
do it the Apple chargers not coming out
can't make it
and whoever [ __ ] came out and they
announced you it's not coming it's David
they literally went yeah we can't do
this they can these parties no they
can't it can't charge three things at
once no no because it will take seven
days and you know what here's the
difference to you know it would never
would have happened with Steve Jobs hey
Steve we can't do this oh really he's a
tyrant oh really you can't do this you
need somebody who's a tyrant to make
[ __ ] happen then I mean this is going
real deep for Apple fanboy geeks yeah
but you know I mean you'd know him if
any of you've ever seen any of the Apple
promo videos know where they're
introducing the new products and you
hear the British guy's voice over it and
then they talk to him that's Johnny I
sit he is designing he is the designer
he worked hand-in-hand with Steve Jobs
everything he loves company he quit told
Steve Jobs have vegetables that'll fix
you I don't think it was working with
Steve a dirt on your [ __ ]
trust me strawberries you know they're
saying they want to cut the - no I don't
have any got no reasonable shrinkage
never sit in the yard and let mosquitoes
bite you though right
have a vitamin C and two herbs [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're the hospital I pour
emergency in this veggie juice it should
do the trick Gabey have you tried Lipton
tea you're Johnny Ives my god you know
what
in this end Johnny I've showed me ask
you this Bob yeah you know from being an
Apple fanboy yourself gets dry every
time he was [ __ ] appears The Wall
Street Journal reported do I feel safer
I feel little baby fingernails on me
when I hear egg nurse horrible The Wall
Street Journal reports yes
the Johnny Ives left because Tim Cook
doesn't care about design Tim Cook goes
that's ridiculous that's not true yeah
and I'm looking at that going I don't
believe Tim Cook even for one second
there's definitely true he's terrible
he's in there going Johnny why don't you
just paint it white and throw an apple
daily on it I believe there's a video
Steve Jobs going and he was talking
about why he left Apple to begin with
him over and he said any time the money
guy them once once creative people to
get together and create something that's
never been before
yeah money people usually follow and he
goes wants money people are involved in
the company creativity design art is
dead yeah yeah they kill it because they
care about the bottom line you know they
make all the money now how [ __ ]
dongles dongles dongles don't hurry Jody
just paint the dongles white and throw
an apple Deeley on the side thanks Tim
you love being that character that's
also gets character Microsoft Ely on the
side does Johnny Ives is yeah does he
have a problem with his legs do you know
that those are his shoulders no no
that's sweater no Matt I'm wondering I
think he has they've never you've never
seen Johnny Ives walking I don't know I
know that he doesn't like he doesn't
like doing the public
stuff there's no video of him walking
and I believe there's something up with
his legs you know wheelchair I don't
know hmm I just I'm a wheelchair wide
throw an apple daily on the side
is he rich I think there's something up
with his legs the way he walks Johnny
Johnny is very rich yeah he's made quite
a bit of my oldest he's like 50 55 maybe
yeah I have no idea but that company's
done nothing but lateral moves and last
since Tim Cook - Katie - it's all left
right left
it's so [ __ ] good look at Samsung and
I hate to say cuz I [ __ ] hate Sam
like Samsung but we paint him wait throw
an apple Deeley on the side you can take
your phone a Samsung and if you don't
have battery I can just put my phone on
top of your phone and it will charge
your phone what that's [ __ ] nuts
everybody every iPhone should have I
can't do this with my I can't do that
with me you can't do [ __ ] with that
phone the only reason the only reason
people still have iPhones is because
they don't want to be a green bubble
it's it was the same thing at the end of
blackberry the only thing that kept
blackberry alive was blackberry
messenger I got cool that's still
popular it's not as popular anymore but
people didn't want to leave bbm I heard
it's coming back you think so yeah
they're with the BBC I think I think
people are gonna go now yeah people
don't wanna be a green bubble they want
to be a blue bubble eventually the
technology will become so ridiculous
that you won't care anymore and you'll
go you know what [ __ ] it I'll just be a
green bubble and there'll be enough
green bubbles you're a green bubble
looks like a text message from Apple
honestly when you get a green bubble on
a group chat you're like okay one of us
is on welfare well I mean like yeah I
know Sam some [ __ ] up the folding
phone yep but it that's the next thing
it'll be a very small phone that folds
out - like on a regular iPhone now like
it won't get bigger it will just be the
same type of phone that you can stick in
your pocket you don't think it'll be
like well what Samsung did iPhone into
tablet I actually think maybe before the
phone it might be computers so instead
of having a like a laptop you'll just
have a they got they got laptops they
fold already but the vine no keyboard it
will just fold out to a big monitor I
say you can you know it's a glass I hate
that to turn on glass is hard though
they'll have they'll have a tactile
response it will feel like you're just
doing a keyboard Oh an extra yeah and
you
every thought the same way about using
your thumbs to type [ __ ] that I need it
I need to touch it yeah you just get
using they're working on one now though
it's gonna be a computer you're like a
paper plane you go for your computer
your friend catches it I can't wait
until they have the like the the glasses
when they figure that [ __ ] out I that's
too much for me
really they tried it with Google glass
right and it was too early well people
get beat up because they're on the train
and people you filming me [ __ ]
no I'm just watching them oh by the way
they have those new teeny tiny little
[ __ ] bug robots that I tweeted about
like the bees in black mirror kind of
yeah but once you put cameras and sound
on those and once the storage is small
enough forget it I mean everybody is
going to be spying on the story it'll be
swords won't be in the B the storage
will be it'll be a museum internal
storage the size of a [ __ ] flying under
a gram then and that's a primitive model
but wait five years ten your fur get it
besides mosquito five or ten before
people can get him no I love technology
we always do do five or ten five ten
years
so watch ya sick but then you look at
iPhones from five or ten years ago and
show about the same the same we better
yeah we talking about storage iCloud
everybody except you uses Ike the iCloud
nobody isn't practically story my ass
Sam you can't put his photos in the air
[Laughter]
his photos are like gold medallions yeah
you have to keep them in a safe they're
really not that is scandalous is just
it's what people would expect it's a
bunch of them different sizes here's the
problems they need to figure out how to
make the batteries stronger and smaller
I say C batteries but a couple seasons
in there absolutely a new phone you know
Jim the phone's a little heavy yeah
we're gonna go see batteries for C
batteries 24 hours talktime
I thought and then you have to just buy
more bad I thought they're gonna modular
phones where you could like take take
like they have like pico projectors yeah
there you can just like clip onto your
phone like take the camera out put a
pico projector on and then shoot an a
hundred inch image on the ground
Motorola tried that but you don't have
it nobody wants 150 accessories for
their phone they just want one deal like
that for your Waldo package while dude
watching a [ __ ] movie off your phone
on a wall is great but was it your whole
movie is it quality good it's fine it's
fine it's not look it's not it's not
gonna be like TV all right you know
whatever not yet oh wait 5 10 years 5 or
10 years yeah you got a little drones
flying around with SD cards you got
movies on your wall till 5 or 10 years
I'm telling you watch watch commercial
flight you see that plane they're making
Boeing's making it would go to Japan in
3 hours
oh my god I tried that with the Concorde
though yes I mean not that quick
obviously but it's too expensive too
yeah because the thing is with the
Concorde you have to get up so high yeah
that they couldn't like you couldn't fly
Concorde you have to go overseas yeah
it's also because they take the the
sound barrier breaking and taking off it
was just too much yeah they said that
they were worried that the the sound
waves would like break glass but they
could have done it they could have done
New York to LA you just take off from
JFK over the water and fly and then over
LA over the Pacific you know like if you
went all the way around the country
instead of across over the country but
you have to just gain your altitude you
don't want to take off over the water
you go if you take off out of New York
you go east a little bit gain some
altitude come back West you might lose a
few minutes you know I think because you
get you have to go to Mach whatever once
you're in the air but yeah when you do
that when you're over land if no no
because the building they said well most
people thought that you could but they
were worried that the building's glass
would break that's why you could only
hit that Mach speed over water which is
why they could and they only had enough
gas to get to like you know Europe or
wherever they were going yeah so it was
super limited in what you could do and
then you know the [ __ ] thing crashed
we have how many for hairline fractures
with Air France plane and help anything
yeah that never helps but in the
disappointing with Apple I'm doing you
just sit there and you're like you
look at this company that you would sit
there and when they would introduce new
products yeah you get excited like you
were watching like a line Oh Ewing I'd
sit there and I would I would watch the
live streams of their corporate press
conferences just to listen to Steve Jobs
go oh and one more thing what do you got
for us Steve because there's always
problems with the new product there's
always something wrong with it has got
to be updated I never watched those
[ __ ] dumb speeches I hated them I
never watched I loved them I would watch
but I would [ __ ] watch him live I had
the the iMac that looked like a snow
globe oh my that was the first wasn't
that the first one no the first one was
that I meant earlier that was at one
time they redefined cool she was talking
about Mac OS matter more I think she was
turned out she was right they were sure
I am I hated her for it but they made
technology cool yeah they're [ __ ]
they were the best Steve Jobs was the
best the best he was of a lot at best
this is the second time this happened
our Bill Gates first time first time has
happened back I believe in the 80s late
80s early 90s when they Sammy's kidding
he's Josh I read that you've known it
longer talk in the 80s he's Josh oh yeah
the same thing happened when they kick
skeet when Steve was when the guy from
Pepsi kicked Steve out to the curb they
started right like yesterday's tomatoes
you had to go to copy us a way to get
Apple right copy will say and they
started going okay they had to they had
their own laser printers like if you're
gonna get a computer I had a Mac classic
with a laser printer Apple laser printer
mm-hmm which was you know weighed 700
pounds but yeah but yeah and that's when
they had no software for Apple like it
sucked no territorial and he [ __ ]
himself they would they because every
nothing worked with with Apple products
it was stupid they isolated themselves
yeah but then and then Bill Gates made
his [ __ ] user friendly if you Jobs
came back and redesigned everything no
Bill Gates yeah I did the design wise
Apple fell the [ __ ] off yes even gone
Steve left the [ __ ] company
this isn't Billy gee make it pop it like
where you can you could buy all these
other developers and designers could
kind of use
windows and that was what gave it 80% of
the world's computers yes
but Steve being gone made it so that
Apple was not cool like there's no
reason I had a Mac during that period
and it was like I just felt like such an
[ __ ] suck everybody had a Windows
computer and you're sitting there my
room and O's I switched
I went to Dell yeah my dad was like no
we're gonna you you were dude you're
getting to Dell dude I went dude you get
to death so cool
I knew that guy got fired for smoking
weed yeah ill who the guy from down the
dude you're getting a Dell guy I don't
remember him yeah he's like their
commercial spokesman he's this a kid who
seems stoned anyway like he was a STONER
kid that's his whole thing smoking pot
yeah they were
when was this in the 90s probably like
very early 2000s yeah yeah
but that went stand they yeah an apple
put out the Newton at that time too I
had one I had to return it to radio show
I knew it was the first handheld palm
device yeah it's like the beginning of
the Palm Pilot back Tom posture coming
back it had it had a phone jack in it
you could stick a phone line in the top
of it right like the plug in I remember
being at a hotel somewhere and I I was
in the way you get breakfast and I was
like can I use that foam bathroom and I
had to I had a stick I remember plugging
the phone line into my Newton yeah it
had handwriting recognition it was the
first device to have handwriting
recognition but it sucked
oh it sucked it took you three hours I'm
a gateway guy though you like to count
back yeah a gateway computer yeah yeah
they still yeah I think but they're more
like for corporate stuff cuz you buy
like it corporations buy a ton of them
cheap yeah but yeah it Steve Jobs came
back and he came back with did you get
nervous about Steve Jobs no did you pass
gas no I thought I heard something Jim
Jim I know we're gonna smell it I'll let
you know in a second okay because Jim's
face he's it started you can see it okay
you see the cheekiness I'm laughing
there what so Steve Jobs what no I
didn't yes you did you're a bad liar
trust me he talks fast mean lies he goes
like this nineteen butters man go ahead
yeah
yes Steve comes back with with the uh
was the iMac the iMac was the first
thing he came back I'm out yeah
when you read you redesigned the
hardware and the software so now all of
a sudden it was like iTunes comes out
iMovie comes up iPhoto
well the iPhone was yet to arrive
therefore the iPhone was the I pod
that's right he iPod and if you remember
the story tell it Steve and his other
guy in charge the iPod they were the big
thing was uh micro chef was trying to
come out with a a tablet that was the
next big thing Rabbids tablets tablets
so Steve the Steve was at a party and
somebody from Microsoft was there and he
said he goes yeah we're coming out we're
gonna be the first ones to come out with
a tablet we're the only ones doing it
and it pissed him off so much this
[ __ ] guy pissed him off so much that
he went back the next day I was like
everybody in we're making a [ __ ]
tablet [ __ ] damn they don't know how to
do it we're gonna do it right here this
whole team come in and figure out how to
touch he said the first one was like a
table we could take stuff and move it
around and and then he's sitting there
and he's he's in the room with this guy
and he's looking around and everybody
was on their phone and they're making
this tablet they're in the prime and
he's looking around he goes you know
what [ __ ] the tablet look around and
they go everybody was on their phone
Hoosick we're gonna make a phone and he
goes everybody has phones we're gonna
make a [ __ ] small tablet phone and he
goes uh there they were like [ __ ]
make it make this smaller see and that's
why is it tired cuz they're like dude we
can't even make it your this is the CEO
you need you need a guy like that will
come in and insist on greatness now you
got a guy who's walking around going
let's clean it and throw a battle dog
but that's not the way that they I
didn't like the swipe thing I thought it
should have been more sound give the
swipes a pain I thought it should have
been like with like like you do that for
it to swipe off like a the clapper yeah
attached to the isolated clapper yeah
I'd be good I think that I think you're
right about that Jack I remember the
oohs and ahhs I did see the first press
conference when they in now or whatever
was when they announced the first iPhone
and when he swiped people were like oh
yeah
it really was the first the first iPhone
announcement was great because he goes
we have three devices today we have the
greatest iPod you've ever seen we have
an Internet communicator and we have a
phone and he goes through and then at
the end he's like and it's all none of
one device and everybody goes no no it's
no no no it's not it is he went how he
did the three things he said phone he
internet communicator and then a
communicator and iPod iPod yeah phone
and getting there goes phone it's the
phone in an iPod phone and he kept doing
it closer close and he goes phone in and
then he showed the one device and we
were like then he goes and we're gonna
have a camera with no flash he didn't
mess that much first of all we got a
flash later having a camera in the flash
it was the biggest dick that's why I
hated Apple because they did it on
purpose so the next version they can
have a flash no they didn't do this on
purpose they did they did not very he
was all hydrogen for Lee Bob they did
they would always hold back on stuff
like that which they knew the upgrade
wouldn't get you and never they were no
that's not it's not that it's not the
upgrade that would get you I think it
would be some of that I'm not saying
it's all that but but they also didn't
do [ __ ] didn't Samsung the reason why
the phone [ __ ] dies and people go to
Apple because when Apple got it it was
perfect
that's what Travis always says I don't
need it to be first I need it to be
right and now where's my mother now they
could have put a flash on it now yeah
but it would have been it would Bob is
right that they hammer with no flight
they go ahead and they don't put
absolutely everything on because
everything is not perfected yet
and it's digital so that what they did
is that internally what's that yogurt
with honey yes they do
they did it with the podcast I'm honey
here's the yogurt they did it inside
because it's a digital camera they could
do it inside
with the with the functionality they can
just rake they can make it absorb more
light so you don't need a flash that's
what they were thinking but even it
still does that even before that when
the iPod was first announced people were
sitting there looking at him they're
like look mp3 players already exists you
know I love a good mp3 player by the way
that's what I'm I have just a separate
mp3 player you like that love it yeah
why well he's like he's like give a
phone he's like baby driver Jim is an
interesting character he's got tonight
and I'd make some super interesting yeah
[Music]
you know my oh [ __ ] you don't have
tomorrow nice I want to call back but
he's good nobody the iPod comes out and
like mp3 players already exist but they
either have low storage or they're
gigantic or whatever or they you know
the operating system is terrible and
like Steve Jobs announces this thing
yeah and everybody thinks he's an idiot
he goes like it's 500 bucks or however
much it was originally so it's super
expensive and who needs an mp3 player we
all got our CD players and that but he
was on to something cuz he realizes what
I don't care what anybody's this is what
people are gonna want yes and there was
a period of time is when I was in
college like in the early 2000s you
couldn't go anywhere without seeing
white earbuds white earbuds were
absolutely everywhere and great earbuds
yeah they were good [ __ ] that's what
the iPad do the first iPod ones I hated
them
you know he my everything that comes up
first it take knows it my ears crop
until some famous delicate ears till
somebody famous goes these are the best
ear I love these oh maybe I like him
till they they didn't fit my ears
properly but I did a hard play you think
of either you liked him he would have
been like Jim I love these headphones if
Ozzie liked about would have ate them no
I didn't I didn't like how they fit me I
wanted to like them so bad I always said
to my second head [ __ ] hated those Jim
one can't we fought the company for not
making a headphone to fit your lumpy
loads no but they couldn't made a couple
different sizes did one size fits all
eventually they did put the rubber
after his [ __ ] [ __ ] - sighs they
came out with three rubber adapter like
the new ones I actually have in my house
I found it the other day a first
generation iPod I have one of those that
says a tough crowd Colin Quinn on the
back oh my gets engraved yeah that's
awesome yeah they gave it out and Colin
was like you want this I was like [ __ ]
yeah yeah still have it
that's Austin's crazy but the the actual
charging cable they don't make anymore
you have to I have to find on eBay or
something yeah it's like the real like
firewire yes yeah yeah huge yeah I had
the same problem because I have the
second generation when it's actually in
the office and and that firewire cable
yeah can't find it anywhere and I wanted
to get songs off of that iPod Lee market
but yeah you gonna be fine I mean this
was like five years ago then now it's
just sitting in my desk drawer here yeah
it holds a charge for like two minutes
but it is it is crazy that we're getting
to the point now where people are
looking at old like classic iPods the
way we were looking at like CD players
like you look at an iPod now and you're
like oh that's so cool and retro it's
funny too because they were the ones
everything you got up until then had
removable batteries yeah like phones you
just take a battery up put a new one
people were like hey Steve is just gonna
have removable battery he was like [ __ ]
that no you're gonna get a new one
because I gotta make a new one next year
and you're gonna go what the [ __ ] and he
goes like this couldn't you just make a
removable battery and he goes yeah but
[ __ ] that yes cuz you know why cuz he
didn't want to put seams on it yeah [ __ ]
seems he didn't want to even what seems
you wanted to be smooth yeah I don't
want seams and that's what that's what
Johnny Ives needed he needed a guy going
like [ __ ] seams right yeah [ __ ] see
seams instead of like oh let's put an
apple Deeley on this Johnny I've said
wisely no he didn't he didn't say but
Wall Street Journal is right it's
because Tim Cook doesn't tear about
design let me tell you some Tim Cook
sucks sucks he does suck everybody
listen he's pretty good for Stockton
there's a Asian canal that does Apple
bites you ever see that I don't think so
so unnecessary you just can't get a
thought out he he does this thing called
Apple buys he's done a few years I
didn't seen that and I loved it because
he would always have the information and
he'd lead up to stop and he was [ __ ]
great he loves Apple his reviews he
hates Apple no he does right he hates it
dude it's so he's got bad reviews to
Apple all the time I was so close I was
going I this is the new and I think it's
the new iPhone I don't know how do you
know could be that could be six I have
no [ __ ] idea
they have no idea I have no clue or is
it the 10 or the 10x or the 10 are
that's like after I buy it I have no
idea which iPhone this is I don't have a
clue it used to be like of course you
would know your identity as a human
being was attached to it men will go to
an Apple store and it was like meeting
aliens they are so smart dude I went to
an Apple store right when I was building
my studio of my house I went to an Apple
store excited to get a new computer to
run everything right and I have a mixer
that I was gonna run into the computer
but and except of course Tim Cook was
like you're gonna mean a dongle for that
I was like then I'll go get a dongle and
I go this is what I knew he's not
perfect by the way they changed the [ __ ]
you and make you buy adapters it's
really but I go ok I'll go buy a whole
bunch of dongles like all kinds it's
just so I have them and I knew Apple was
finished when I go to the Apple store I
go to the dongle section and I pick up a
dongle and I go to the sales guy and I
go hey I've got a pretty significant
mixer that I'm gonna be plugging into
the computer it's a USB mixer will this
dongle be able to handle that kind of
power and he takes the box and he goes
well and he starts reading the back of
the box yeah you're done and I go that's
Best Buy yeah thanks thanks quad yeah by
the way there now the guy no idea what
you're selling that's Radio Shack the
radio the new a brand new camera can
they stop with the [ __ ] camera I
thought you liked a camera with the
flash I love it but if that's all they
do that sorry I didn't pick up JJ hammer
a little bit [ __ ] instinct for the first
time when I was going to get this iPhone
I was so close to actually getting the
galaxy 3 I was I was so close and I
looked at it and I was
it's just it's soaked it's not yet who
operating systems - that's the problem
yeah give everything and I never
compounded really close I almost went to
the ten the new the with the note the
big one yeah yeah yeah I almost went to
that this year I was this close to going
to Verizon getting the whole new phone I
mean they give you two phones and and
just just the functionality of a Samsung
and all the [ __ ] it can be good the [ __ ]
they can do is amazing but then you hear
like okay everybody who's ever went from
Apple always comes back yeah that wraps
is always in there going like whoa you
know the operating system the updates
aren't Universal so if the system
updates it might not update for your
phone and I'm like oh there's already
complications Travis you're in my head
I'll get the goddamn iPhone Travis does
a better job than Tim Cook quite frankly
by the way I've been bashing Tim Cook in
cooks just a week he's terrible people
get mad well you bet you he sucks the
guys sucks what if I put an Apple TV on
the side you can't even come out with a
case that you can put your ice iPods in
that charges your iPods like come out
with a [ __ ] battery case that you can
just stick your iPods in and when we
arrive your iPod Jerry I mean right your
iPods your headphones the new wireless
in case doesn't charge the thing I thank
you but I don't want to carry that two
things I want to be able to plug my my
headphones in my case so the case that
you want a case for the phone that you
can put your so my your headphones
they're always with me you know I'm
gonna tell you something Bob Kelly
that's very reasonable you got to carry
this little joke around with you you
gotta carry this little joke around you
just if he hasn't come out with
something like that yeah they probably
do but the fact that never reasonable
the fact that Apple hasn't done it the
fact that Apple hasn't come out with a
new Johnny probably thought of it
[ __ ] keyboard a better keyboard and
case for the iPad pro now I gotta say
something let me back up back up the
iPad pro that they just came out with is
the [ __ ] greatest device I've ever
owned from Apple cuz it's big
no oh it's so powerful it does so much
[ __ ] and it's wrong I mean
I can hook my my GH five camera right
into it and just send [ __ ] to it
there's the pros the one that has the
pen right that's it I think I don't if I
have gotten it yet that is your [ __ ]
well you're able to hook up your your
camera to it because you got the right
dongle I don't take care well no cause
uh we're just gonna see the USB see so
it goes right into the bottom right in
my camera oh my G h5s what's that that's
a high end you know video it's a you
know like you can shoot a movie with it
oh but this [ __ ] iPad is the [ __ ] I
don't even take my my you edit Maddie's
on it
do they ever they have an app called
luma fusion that the it's it's the most
incredible [ __ ] app if you're doing
YouTube content and you don't use luma
fusion you're out of your [ __ ] by the
way I brought my iPad my funer and I
tried to use like Microsoft Word on I
mean a [ __ ] final draft and it stunk
it wasn't compatible I was so irritated
trying to do stuff on my iPad that I was
doing on my lap I think there may be a
higher probability of operator error no
it was not compatible channel because I
used my I used my I used my final draft
on my iPad all the time maybe operator
error there's you know all the time I
use it I I don't even take my laptop my
macbook pro with me anymore leave it a
thousand what slow motion that looks
amazing
listen to me man by the way I saw Bob
Sam wrote it down this is you know my
notebook is very important to me can you
do this now this luma fusion is the
easiest it's it's a different luma
version version and they just came out
with an update that's [ __ ] it I think
it's I believe it's six rows of video
six rows of audio I mean green screen
stuff you can do they have every [ __ ]
thing and it's connected to all your
videos on your iPad your iPad so you
take the videos on your phone or
wherever you get them and you can you
just airdrop them to your iPad and
they're right [ __ ] there this thing
is the best I mean [ __ ] everything else
I was learning all that you know the the
high-end editing stuff what is it
premiere yeah Premiere Pro this thing
blows it away don't you hate when you
try I hate
edit something with with a [ __ ] swipe
on a glass when your foot very much you
use the pencil all for that use the ball
I told you you'd need a pencil
yeah ideally on the side of the pencil
you know it so imagine if you love luma
okay and not mom and you can have it
anyway it's not gonna grab it he just
wanted to say the name I guess I
actually will look he's pretty good I
think do you understand the amount of
problems you're gonna have with it I
don't think it's the app how much is it
I'm gonna I'm gonna download it huh 30
bucks
oh my god I yell at any price what's
great about to inside the app they have
sound effects but they also have royalty
free music get out of town so but you it
was sixty bucks for the year or
something like that for this functional
fifty bucks
it's [ __ ] unbelievable did you edit
your like shed shows on it on this no I
edit everything I do on this now I see
yeah like you can't believe it yeah Star
Wars I know Baba shed talk you don't owe
you do the whole [ __ ] show I use a rake
talking to a friend we got Vash you got
Bob you got a rake I just put the Colin
Quinn episode out on YouTube for free oh
yeah that's a episode it was a day
before his heart attack and he'll get
private question stressful was that me
some lumison dude it's good so you like
it
here's the other two you can take like
we do like if you guys are doing an
interview or something
take a wide shot and then in this you
can just zoom in you can make four shots
out of one shot so you zoom in and then
huh and you can make a close-up at a
close-up or closer to unless it seems
like honestly and this is maybe very
nerdy of me it seems like it would be
fun like to do it on your iPad never
using your hands you have a good time
don't you feel like Minority Report
exactly yes you do all sync up though
like the audio I feel are there any sync
ability problems you stop trying to be a
tech guy I want to know
words you can hook up a high-end
microphone to it so I have a Sennheiser
$1,000
movie microphone you're gonna get up to
the iPad hook it up to the iPad so when
you do like voiceover you know inside
stuff it sounds [ __ ] crazy I only
went for my iPhone I've gotten nothing
none of them so far so maybe I need to
switch up and I wonder you know I know a
little microphone you put plug in one
would you recommend it I wonder if I use
a dongle USB CD USB if I could plug a
sound board into the iPad yes you can oh
there's actually God there's a thing I
believe ASIC a some one of those
companies llama fussion you can know as
a luma you can you can slide the iPad in
and it's an actual mixing board sorry
case stop it so you can just slide it
and it has XL hours in the back stop it
what's an XLR he just started taking the
train a year ago now I've been sipping
around on the other saying he goes to
comedy club after comedy club radio
studio after radio to you has been 30
years of this that's right and you
didn't know what an XLR came that remiel
of trying to tell him until busy what is
the name of this thing now Bob I'm gonna
put this in my notebook - what is the
name of this thing well there's a bunch
of them there's a llama [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's a Mac it isn't oh yes put the
iPad Francis you slide it right in and
you can plug mics into it and it's a
mixing board and everything there's an
app you open up it's [ __ ] crazy
stop it that's crazy that's pretty
[ __ ] I tried to learn editing it
didn't go well
no no I'm just too impatient for it I
get annoyed at what kind of you mean
video editing yeah for the videos that I
put up I'm too impatient bro you you you
got you have a young boy you don't need
to learn anything can I ask a retainer
trans guys are you sure you can get luma
fusion on your phone is that how you
pronounce it no ma I'm getting luma
fusion on your phone and you can edit
videos in it I hate trying bro anger
though it doesn't work can't even read a
newspaper anymore he's got old man eyes
he's not editing movies I'm like I can't
do it I try to do it like [ __ ] too far
far so far huh you try to dragon he's
got edited videos on the texts you know
what I mean no I'm still I'm still
hanging on for my bunny
I said need the pictures I hate your
budgets just editing your video Steve
bunny eyes on yes I do
but I still want to learn to do it
myself it's good to do you got a young
boy on retainer bring it get the one on
they get a little effusion for the iPad
I don't think that's what it's that's
princess looma I use my iPad let's have
a summation we'll watch stuff on I mean
can I tell you something yeah please I
think I might buy an iPad pro over the
weekend and and a pencil just to do this
dude it is the best I just got all
excited about it I bought my macbook
after I bought the iPad pro put it on
the business I don't even [ __ ] use
the MacBook I use just my I take it on
the road stop it
the the that and I hate the keyboard you
need there's what I also use too because
I make you know when you want to make
intros and stuff like like texts and
stuff yeah I use procreate so what you
can do this is a fun I like to procreate
I did it twice so I don't know if you
know this but in your phone if you did
you can record the screen on your yeah I
don't you can it's great for dirty
[ __ ] FaceTime chats imagine the
amazing porn videos you can make though
Jim with this kind of editing software
you take your face times you take your
texts you can edit them all together
nice just off compilation so you know
you see a video and then you want to put
it on and you want to take a video off
the YouTube wherever it is and put it in
one of your videos or whatever and you
got to go and download you don't do that
all you have to do with this is swipe
down record your screen playing the
video and then bring it into luma fusion
cropped it to box so it looks like it's
the video I'm gonna tell you something
yeah yeah I just had this I we got like
a you know a swing setting a slide and
everything for the boy yeah I got one
yeah of course a little Westchester I
think it's mandatory it is mandatory
yeah how didn't you hate things in the
backyard I look down upon when you'd
have your shorts on and your skin would
go like that joke particularly well well
you were a boy and you go down the
sliding pond and your legs would get
scraped up against the metal that's not
what you're like getting scraped up
against when you were a boy hey my knees
were on the concrete a sliding pond
what's a slide I don't know sliding pond
like we know what it is you've made
something you've made something no I
have not
a sliding pause this is a jersey thing
Bob but they don't have sliding ponds in
question I'm from Jersey I've never
heard of this that's what it's just
think it was slide slide high-fiving
pond nobody calls it sliding pond that's
the proper no it's ever called this
everyone knows what a [ __ ] [ __ ] kid
you were that you found it the proper
name for a slide it's just a slide yeah
it is the same thing but it's not me can
I write the sliding pond
why not horse Jimmy make sure your
friends go down first you don't hurt
anybody on the slide but Jimmy check to
see if it's hot with your tongue you
don't have burn you thought was the
worst but you know when I did Bob stop
saying sliding pause it wasn't sliding
it's not a slide we just looked it up I
get the sliding pond for the house
that's good boy and I left and we show
the kid for the first time he's going
nuts he's climbing everything and I'm
taking all these videos with my iPhone
and I thought it would be fun send to
the parents I doubt I took all the
videos dumped him to my computer then
dump them all in Final Cut then started
editing then I had to go to a website
find royalty-free music so I could add a
bed in then I added a bed in then I
exported to like Vimeo or something like
that private link send it along I could
have done all that yeah with Lema
fussing little fusion here's the thing
is when you open up your right when you
open to be van all in there because it's
in the cloud it's already in your iPad
of course it is okay now Vimeo is
already in luma fusion I don't think
it's pronounced that way but okay it so
you go when you're when you're actually
when you're exporting Vimeo is in me Oh
Vimeo is in luma fuses so you just go
hey why don't want to put this on
whatever you want to do it on there's
like 30 choices you know much of it
YouTube Google Drive it wherever the
[ __ ] you want to pay the eight Google
Drive I love Google Drive of course you
eight Google you hate what do you not
hate why would you not like Google Drive
I like it why because you try it when I
try to open something on my iPhone from
Google Drive it never plays whatever I'm
opening video never plays you need to
hate yourself it's operator error and
now I'm know you hit the button play and
that little [ __ ] that little like
white circle with a line through it
comes
won't play cuz you [ __ ] up because you
[ __ ] up though I can't stop air
dropping air drops I never used it I
just about a month ago wait didn't you
wait till you find out how great iCloud
it's do you know old air dropping is
like that was over since World War one
it was called bomb I let me you gotta
bump your phone yeah it had like it is a
separate app yeah yeah but the palms had
the we would shoot the yep I can shoot
the number to you I air drop so much me
and I love it
yeah I did so you ever just be on the
train and open up your drop us use open
I did I just send it like take a picture
of you going like this and send it to
them and then look at them dude in there
in the office crazy
hey they laugh every time today oh yeah
they can't cuz they're looking on their
phone and they're like okay and then
they look up and you're just going oh I
was air dropping gifts to like the
intern and to handsome Rob in the office
yesterday just unannounced yeah and like
giggling to myself about it and then
they would just look at me like we do
what you doing this stupid number the
time he requested $20 from me I do I
didn't know you could request money you
can just hit on your iPhone in the text
you can just hit request money so I can
just request the I know I've gotten
those requests you know he's the only
person that's ever accepted the request
and sent me money hot dog
really yeah yeah my guy my my young boy
he was like okay and then he thought he
was gonna get me back this is my
favorite part
he was like okay like I I'm gonna get
him back I'm gonna send him a request
but he didn't send me a request he just
sent me more money and I accept a
Starbucks gift card to write in the text
message how do you um airdrop just from
your phone no I always have to we have
to open the the image or video okay I
could do that you know I leave my
airdrop open for whoever just in case
something fun comes through okay that
makes ya know why not I think mines open
I don't know [ __ ] it you know what I
mean I don't think yours is open
probably not there's probably some kind
of operator ever yeah no there is right
there is open right
just like that it's awesome you like
that yes you love that yes yeah I'm
telling you you love airdrop one day
it's gonna happen you're gonna start
using the cloud and you're gonna go oh
my god how much better is that's how
much a the cloud can suck my [ __ ]
MobileMe was 10 years ago 15 years ago
MobileMe mobled me how long ago was
mobile me Troy can you look up the whole
omegas mobile me that was there Apple's
original it was from henan would eat up
[ __ ] it I would lose a month of
information it's stunk I came out in
like 2002 decline that did you see it I
just declined it oh yeah
I thought you want to see this know the
climate you know hair drops are fun okay
all right you guys I'm on the radio show
do you know I'm telling you about how I
just am Dan airdrop to Bob people would
like some air-dropped content being
delivered for the money they're paying
for these subscriptions use decline it
you have to accept my it's a lot of
operator I'm finding Bob's airdrop all
right by the way we do want to speaking
of all this technology and everything I
think Jim and I would like to let
everybody know yeah we went on the air
yesterday and did a whole thing about
the YouTube channel and everything
that's going on 24 hours later we do
have an announcement we're going right
back to the way things used to be the
full videos are going back
yeah the YouTube channel I made a big
stink about it we were right and then
had a nice reasonable discussion yes
people afterwards yes there it's very
nice to have people in certain levels of
Management here that are listening and
able to comprehend what is being said
yeah it was and the conversation was uh
was pleasant it was like well this is
the reason and the person said all right
yeah that makes sense right it was very
it was like you if they heard it and
they listened and it was just great our
version of this will work out best for
not only us but for the company as well
so as of now you know handsome Rob is
gonna is and it's not allowed to use
profanity anymore on the air
well we won't we don't want it to right
why we want to clean it up we want to be
more brand friendly going for a rest
real energy on this show yeah we want to
attract
new sponsors and also Gemini her a
little more woke than we used to be
that's right I think that's a fancy idea
no more profanity on the air you know
what I'm sick of it too I don't want to
swear anymore either
yeah I think it's like [ __ ] it you know
what I mean whoa well that's jumping
ship is dumping yeah keep down below yes
when you don't do it for a couple
minutes it's shocking yeah well that's
what I want we like to set the
boundaries is that eventually we can
push through that's right it forward you
know name yes I've always said I've
never seen an envelope that I don't like
to push crazy
I said envelope I meant stool but yes
we've heard all of you and then Sirius
has heard all of you and as of right now
we're going back to the way things were
before we're gonna upload full segments
to the YouTube channel you know what
Travis let Rob know I think that we
don't need to do the whole hour and 15
minutes but I think tech talk all the
Apple talk we just did [ __ ] it let's put
it on video let's put it on the channel
yeah bite they should break it up I use
if it into a thing yet it do it on the
ocean drop start using a llama from a
foo shun it's not francha German it's
actually a little efficient the
Microsoft it's a fusion I think it is
the most luma fusion if you love my
version dude that company how is this a
lot of money for all that
various appliance you know and they're
coming out with another update that's
gonna be crazy what's it gonna do it's
uh uh it's gonna do a bunch more [ __ ]
you can download happy birthday tells
you right there scroll down six video
tracks an audio track you said what's
that mean for what for fall I see okay
what means six tracks is that like six
windows open at the same time Oh
what is six tracks when you edit there's
multiple tracks each angle each camera
angle would be a track and you lay them
on top of each other whatever is the top
track is the one that you're seeing but
that's how you edit through
we like trains no not train tracks where
you lay them on top of each other it's
all on a screen
Thank You Travis oh yeah you can
actually use an external monitor with
this now too
you can show me somebody looking over my
shoulder swear to god stop this I'm not
gonna stop oh my god did you hear one
side what is that he said I don't need
somebody looking over my shoulder
because he took external monitor as like
a person monitoring yeah it's gotta be
the stupidest thing I've heard all this
little joke I'm my eye is twitching
it's so stupid you think it's cute
Travis is cute what did you rescue you
no no no no not you guys it wasn't bad I
like to be a group think it's cute
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM a/v